an update to a story that we shared here  on monday  this is the woman charged with leaving  her dog in a hot car  while she was shopping this happened  last friday at the goodwill on the west  side of town  according to her arrest report this is  the second time that alexandra evans  has done this left her car in a vehicle  less than a week before  that dog was rescued by officers and  then taken to the animal foundation  evans picked him up a few days later you  can see in this video he's wearing a  cone  another reminder that if you come across  a situation like this  call police because only they can  legally break a car window and rescue an  animal